certainly now is christina bob attorney
for president trump uh she was on the
side of mar-a-lago when the fbi raided
president trump's home christina good to
see you so
i want to get your take on this so we
have liberal commentators saying that
boxes and president trump's basement
are a risk to national security however
hillary clinton's server that any
foreign entity that is not a fan of the
united states of america can access is
not as dangerous what say you
yeah absolutely the warrant proves that
everything the democrats have been
pushing down our throats for the last
few days is absolute baloney none of it
passes muster this warrant is clearly
politically motivated and for no other
reason as you mentioned in your
monologue the fact that the warrant was
signed on a friday most likely a friday
afternoon august 5th you know they
didn't want to work on the weekend so
let's take the weekend to think about it
you know regroup on monday and what's
even
weirder about this is this grave
national security matter that was so
important that we had to violate
fundamental rights of a president of the
united states the judge gave them two
weeks to execute it the the warrant
didn't expire until august 19th and it
was signed on august 5th meaning they
had two weeks to execute this so you
want me to believe that this was a grave
matter of national security that
warranted violating constitutional
principles and you could take your time
that doesn't pass muster usually
warrants are executed immediately upon
getting the signature yeah and christina
he had them for a year and a half he had
the documents for a really long time if
they were so sensitive they would have
come and got them on day three or day
four not you know 160 plus days after
but i want to i want i want some clarity
on this so we know the feds came to
mar-a-lago in june they asked for
documents yeah you said you know we've
provided those documents to the feds
since that time in june and sin
to the time of this raid on august 8th
did they ask for any additional
documents from team trump
not to my knowledge not to the knowledge
of the attorneys working on this case so
the last communication you know they
came down in june we showed them around
president trump met with them briefly
said hello it was very nice uh the
agents actually were nice it was a nice
meeting and then after they saw the
storage unit they followed up with the
washington dc lawyers and said you know
we'd really like you to put another lock
on that storage unit we'd like to see it
more secure they said sure absolutely
that was done within i think two days of
their trip down to mar-a-lago and then
after that the next communication that
any of us had heard was oh we're gonna
raid the place so there there was
nothing between hey we'd like you to put
this lock on the door and oh by the way
we're going to bust through the same
lock that we just asked you to put on
the door well none of that listen if if
uh if if you have top secret documents
that are a national security threat i'm
sure all the lawyers would have known
about that it would have been a big news
at mar-a-lago that said hey we got some
documents that the doj wants back you
know you'd all be working on that issue
and that you didn't know is probably
evidence that they didn't ask for other
documents but you were there at
mar-a-lago when the fbi raided the place
do you know what was in the boxes that
they took
well it was documents that's all i know
but i mean as you can look at the list
you know box a1 isn't exactly
descriptive they also didn't leave the
location you know they searched three
areas of the property they searched the
presidential office they searched the
residence and then they searched the
storage area and they could have taken
them from anywhere and so we we don't
even know where they took it from so no
at this point we don't necessarily know
what was in the boxes but i also think
it's important to point out as you did
earlier that president trump had
declassified everything there was
nothing classified so even if they want
to say that documents had classification
markings on them that doesn't mean they
were still classified they had been
declassified so uh the fact that they
put the classification on the inventory
to me
was because they thought that it would
get out to the press you know we want to
make it public and they wanted something
to say oh look at he kept classified
documents none of it is classified none
of it you know christina one last
question for you this search warrant was
so broad that they could look for any
piece of paper that was folded up in any
nook or cranny which for me as a husband
says that they could go to melania's
closet which i hear they did but they
could go through her panty drawer that's
how that's how broad this search warrant
was they could look at every personal
item in the residence of uh the trumps
which i think is absolutely disgraceful
yeah it is and they they expect all of
us now at this point as americans to
just hold the fbi in such high regard
that we say well yes of course that's
totally appropriate it's for the sake of
law enforcement and i think
i think they've just got arrogant gotten
arrogant in their position and what they
believe and you know acting like we have
absolute power and can do whatever we
want the fact that they even showed up
at mar-a-lago to do this shows that
they've gotten way too comfortable with
their power and i think it's about time
the american people reign it in so
christina one last quick question have
you seen the affidavit to the warrant
have you seen that no that is that has
remained sealed we never got a copy of
it and uh i i would love to see a copy
of it and it would be interesting to see
if as would have anything relating to
nuclear i think america wants to see
that affidavit yeah christina thanks for
your great work and thanks for joining
me tonight appreciate it thank you so
much hey sean hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to fox news youtube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most compelling analysis you will
not get it anywhere else